Oh
it's a of course a very vexing issue
because people who believe devoutly in
religion will tell you that there's no
question there it's already answered
which is that we're obligated to respect
and believe and follow the Word of God
however that word is determined I did
with a colleague of mine who had been at
the UCLA Medical School head of the
psychiatric Research Institute
Michael McGuire a book called God's
brain in which we were I think able to
suggest if not demonstrate that religion
is really made by the brain it's a
secretion of the brain and this gets us
away from the issue of whether religion
is true or not true the fact is that
there are 4,200 religions in the world
each of them believing that they're
absolutely correct and everyone should
follow their views and and some 90% of
the human beings are describable by
themselves if not others as religious so
we're not dealing here with a casual
casual phenomenon even though no one has
any evidence of the stories behind the
religions and so we got interested in
this massive unreality which is in fact
finally a real reality namely religions
and so there are cathedrals and towns
there are tax exemptions there are
people donating money to religion still
in America religions receive more
donations than any other part of the
community and so we were fascinated with
what animated this and as I said I think
we were able to suggest if not also
demonstrate that the brain creates
religion and the brain consumes religion
yes that that's the argument that
Michael McGuire discerned in the matter
of serotonin he discovered that
serotonin in primates was associated
with high status and that when animals
had high status they felt better
not unreasonable if you took away their
high status their serotonin levels would
crash their brains would begin producing
more cortisol and other
neurotransmitters that are associated
with feeling mean and feeling bad and
feeling low and so we decided that one
of the ways of looking at religion is to
what extent and how does it generate the
ceratin Sarah - no Journal juices that
make us feel good hence you go to a mass
in a major Cathedral or anywhere about
or a slum Baptist Church and there's
music and there's color and there's
activity and it appears that people
actually get some brain juice out of it
and that brain juice again self-created
and self consumed is the story we think
of religion
well there's an argument about Europe
which has tended in the years recent
years to become less formally religious
so the French for example rarely go to
to mass there are certain fictional
religious observances but they don't
really abide by it on the other hand
they're the most enthusiastic pill
poppers in Europe and it may be that
they're taking the mass into their skull
with a pill so there is the
pharmacological element of brain
soothing let me just back up for a
second what we described was a kind of
malaise of the brain we call brain pain
that's when you're late for work when
you you're driving somewhere vital and
you get a flat tire you're working with
somebody who's a certified moron you
have brain pain and everybody has that
it's in the nature of the human brain to
observe to seek out and to conjure up
problems evaluate the environment in
contrast we suggested that one of the
things that religions do is provide
brain soothing then they soothe the
brain the way a spa does or a massage or
exercise or going for a walk in the park
and so there is a kind of bracket here
between brain pain brain sue and
religion maybe one of the main producers
of the brain soothing phenomenon in a
way that's not that expensive or
destructive or difficult all you have to
do show up Sunday morning